the cost function of the nearest our
transfer algorithm have a Content cost
component and a style cost component
let's start by defining the content cost
component remember that this is the
overall cost function of the neural
style transfer algorithm so let's figure
out what should the content cost
function be let's say that you use
hidden layer L to compute the content
cost if L is a very small number if you
use a layer 1 then it would really force
your generate the image to pixel values
very similar up to your content image
whereas if you use a very deep layer
then it's just asking well if there's a
dump in your content image then make
sure there's a dog somewhere and you
generate an image so in practice the
layer L chosen is somewhere in between
is neither too shallow nor too deep in
the neural network and because you play
this yourself in the programming
exercise that you didn't end it this
week I'll leave you to gain some
intuitions with the concrete examples in
the programming exercise as well but
usually L is chosen to be somewhere in
the middle of the layers of the neural
network neither too shallow nor too deep
what you can do is then use a pre
trained confident maybe AVG network or
it could be some other neural network as
well and now you want to measure given a
content image and given a generated
image how similar are they in content so
let's let this a supersuit square
bracket around racket c and this be the
activations of layer L on these two
images on the images C and G so if these
two activations are similar then that
would seem to imply that both images
have similar content so what we'll do is
define J content C comma G as just how
different how sooner how different are
these two activations so we'll take the
element wise difference between these
hidden unit activations in layer
between when you pass in the content
image compared to when you pass in the
generated image and take that squared
and you can have our normalization
constant in front or not such as 1 over
2 or something else it doesn't really
matter since this will be can be
adjusted as well by this hybrid
parameter alpha so just be clear I'm
using this notation as if both of these
have been unrolled into vectors so then
this becomes the squared of the l2 norm
between this and this
after you've unrolled down both in two
vectors but it's really just the
element-wise sum of squared differences
between these two activation but it's
really just the element-wise sum of
squares of differences between the
activations in layer l between the
images C and G and so when later you
perform gradient descents on J of G to
try to find a value of G so that the
overall cost is low this will
incentivize the algorithm to find an
image G so that these hidden their
activations are similar to what you got
for the content image so that's how you
define the content cost function for
neuro style transfer Nick's
let's move on to the style cost function